Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people.
We do calls on the Friday show via Discord,
which you can find at David Pacman dot com
slash discord. I want to go next to George
from Virginia. George from Virginia. Welcome
to the program. What's on your mind today?
George, you're on the air. George,
you probably have the wrong audio
device selected. If you can fix that,
we will then be able to hear you.
All right, George. Well, unfortunately,
the technical issues plaguing George.
Let's go to Dustin from Hamilton. Now,
Hamilton could be I don't know how many
states have a Hamilton. I think there's even
a Hamilton. There's. There's probably Hamilton
in Canada as well. So, Dustin from Hamilton,
I don't know where you're really calling from.
Maybe you can tell us what's on your mind today.
Okay. Dustin from Hamilton, are you there? Dustin,
you've now muted yourself. Please unmute yourself.
All right. Two in a row, folks, this is not
common. Let's go to Freddie from the Bay Area,
California. I will soon be in the Bay Area in
California. It's going to be a beautiful thing.
Freddie, what's going on?
Speaker 3:
All right. Hey, thanks for taking my call.
Pleasure. I was I don't know if we talked
about this already. I kind of joined in a
little late. Okay. But I was just wondering
your thoughts on the Jorge Santos indictments.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. On the Wednesday show,
we talked about it pretty extensively. I have
to tell you, I am not the type of person to
take pleasure in the failings of others, but I am
delighted by the arrest of George Santos because
not because I go around saying I don't like your
politics and you lied. So you should get arrested.
Not because of that, but because there's so
much evidence against the guy. Exactly. His
actions warrant criminal charges, and now he's
going to have to deal with it and maybe he'll
end up getting kicked out of Congress. Who knows?
Speaker 3: Right. That's what I'm thinking. Like,
what do you think's going to happen? I mean,
do you think hopefully he actually, you know,
gets in trouble for this and doesn't
actually be able to stay in Congress?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. And, you know, the truth
is, with this guy, people are already talking
about prison time. I don't even care about that. I
just want him out of the House of Representatives.
It seems like it would be a moral wrong for him
to have gotten away with what he got away with
and to serve out his full two years. I want him
to suffer the humiliation of being kicked out
of Congress early. And by the way, I don't have
in front of me what the rules are about how you
qualify for like the retirement packages from
Congress, which are fantastic. My thought is if
he doesn't make it a full term, he doesn't get any
of them, which would also be a really great thing.
Speaker 3: Right? Yeah. He doesn't deserve any
of that. It's just the way that he farts around.
It's almost like he likes the attention and going
out, going to parties and stuff. It's just like,
Come on. He doesn't deserve any of that.
Speaker 1: The guy's pathetic. He adds nothing,
he adds. He really is. Freddy, can I ask you a Bay
Area question and get your advice? Sure. So when
I'm going to be out there, I am going to basically
have commitments partially in San Francisco and
partially in Santa Cruz. So my idea was to stay
somewhere roughly in between. And so I only have
to drive half the distance when I go to one or
the other. People have said to me, maybe look at
Palo Alto or Mountain View or whatever. That seems
to be a little closer to San Francisco than Santa
Cruz. But my question to you is.
Speaker 3: Where do you mean?
Speaker 1: Coachella includes where would
be a convenient place to stay with a nice,
walkable downtown with some hipster coffee shops
and the whole thing that would be relatively
convenient to both cities? What do you recommend?
Speaker 3: Okay, So Palo Alto. Yes, that area. And
there's a town called Saratoga. Okay. Right. When
you go up and over the Santa Cruz Mountains, yes,
you're closer to Santa Cruz, but you want to be
closer to Santa Cruz right now, maybe closer to
San Francisco? No, it's Saratoga. I used to have
to stay there. I was bringing my dog to a bed up
there, actually. Okay. Talking about little
hipster places. Coffee. Good little places
to eat. Small, quaint. Very nice. Good little
hotels. That's a great place. Little parks to
go walking. I have I have an 18 month old little
girl, and she was probably eight months old at
the time. And we're bringing her in the stroller
to these little parks and stuff. Fantastic place,
Saratoga. I'm down in Monterey right now, so I'm.
Speaker 1: Going to look into that Friday. That
sounds good. That sounds very good. I'm going
to check into that. I appreciate the advice.
Speaker 3: Yeah, no problem at all.
Speaker 1: All right. There is already
from the Bay Area. A beautiful phone call,
folks. I have to say. Absolutely fantastic.